ce qui m'a amené à l'aviation c'est le
mot d'élise j'ai commencé par faire des
maquettes et des commandes et est allé
faire voler quand j'étais tout gamin
avec mon père exactement donc c'est
comme ça que j'ai eu le goût du pilotage
et la envie de faire tourner des avions
dans toutes les dimensions
voilà vous faire à mesure que j'ai
grandi mais j'avais envie de commencer à
être dedans et d'apprendre à les piloter
donc c'était d'abord je suis venu
pilotes dont j'avais 17 ans 18 ans vous
faire à mesure j'ai dû m'arrêter parce
que il ya la fac et puis financièrement
ses clés m un choix donc voilà j'ai
repris en école d'ingénieur tu
progresses disons que tu commences
survie place et ensuite tu passes sur
monoplace et en fonction des résultats
que tu fais ben si tu es bien classé
on vient de chercher de sélectionner
pour entre l'équipe de france et faire
des stages qui permettent de représenter
la france ensuite à haut niveau
c'est un championnat en france c'est
déjà un événement comme mounir sportif
on reçoit à domicile
donc c'est déjà sympa de faire une super
fête aérienne ça c'est clair et net
ensuite c'est un championnat donc bien
sûr on va donner le meilleur de soi même
et bien sûr pour arriver à ce genre de
championnat
c'est du haut niveau look et une
préparation mentale importante parce que
c'est là se joue sur 14 figurent donc ça
fait à peu près cinq minutes de vol donc
c'est hyper dense c'est hyper précis ça
tombe très vite donc il faut donner le
maximum dans un temps très court
en tenant compte du stress de la fatigue
donc il faut gérer tout ça et en plus
c'est physique
donc il faut vraiment arriver en forme
pouvoir être au meilleur de sa
performance qui est sûr c'est qu'on
essaie d'être de se préparer de ce
faux-pas de s'isoler comme on vient de
se concentrer et de se recentrer sur ce
qu'on a à faire en vol à gérer vraiment
mais il faut gérer le vent faut gérer sa
fatigue
enfin son état de forme et il faut
arriver à 100% donc il n'ya pas de
vraiment de faut apprendre à se
connaître pour réussir à
à donner le milieu de ce qu'on peut
faire en championnats du monde
je donne le meilleur de moi même c'est
mon objectif après il se passera ce qui
se passera a dû cesser si on parle de
voltige aérienne apprécié ces techniques
et puis fille un facteur chance et puis
à différents trucs
si tu veux c'est déjà réussir à donner
le meilleur de soi même c'est hyper
compliqué que ce challenge a qui est
super intéressant si super difficile
c'est un sport de concentration et de
précision
et donc voilà après chacun d'hommes ce
qui peut donner ensuite on voit à la fin
il y aura un classement